ilopongo in what's now el salvador
produced 87 cubic kilometers of ejecta
and had devastating effects on the
mayans
at the same time up in scandinavia a
culture was dying out this was a
precursor culture to what we later
called the vikings historians have
debated why this culture waned and
disappeared and there were probably a
number of reasons but it couldn't have
helped that in a part of the world that
was already famous for cold weather and
marginal
agriculture they got hit with a series
of incredibly cold winters
no direct accounts survive but the
nordic cultures that arose afterwards
may have preserved some cultural memory
of the event in their stories for them
the end of the world
would come not in fire but in ice a
terrible winter called the thimble
winter or the mighty winter so here's a
passage from the edda
first of all that a winter will come
called fimble winter then snow will
drift from all directions there will
then be great frosts and keen winds the
sun will do no good there will be three
of these winters together and no summer
between
another edict poem the crs's prophecy
states black become the sun's beams in
the summers that follow weather is all
treacherous the sun starts to blacken as
the sun vanishes the stars fall into the
sea
where their heat raises a great steam
that covers the sky
the finnish kalivala contains the
following what wonder blocks out the
moon what fog is in the sun's way that
the moon gleams not at all and the sun
shines not at all
parenthetically i'd be remiss if i
didn't point out what's probably obvious
to all of you which is that these
legends of anomalous long winters that
change the course of human
destiny are of course fundamental to
george r r martin's song of ice and fire
aka game of thrones